not macht erfinderisch das dachten sich
wohl auch epa meisinger und ihr mann
armin holz die beiden betreiben ein
swingerclub in bad abbach auf 800
quadratmetern
wir haben jetzt zwei jahre lang
investiert haben den klub auf vordermann
gebracht aus dem bereich gestaltet und
wie man in den endzügen worden kaum
corona stadt drinnen dem liebesspiel
nachzugehen können die gäste nun den
biergarten nutzen die ihnen hat das
ehepaar komplett selbst ausgebaut mit
einer gaststätten genehmigung dürfte eva
und armin ihren swingerclub niveau
betreiben
hier lautet das motto wechseln im
biergarten s6 findet immer im kopf statt
oder viel im kopf statt und unsere gäste
seien echt begeistert von unserer idee
führt uns herum natürlich mit abstand
und dem einhalten der hygieneregeln
ja das ist unser biergarten ganz was
besonderes friebe oder biergarten gibt
es überall hier sind die leute
biergarten outfit und manchmal ganz nah
dann haben wir uns am pool um
verschiedene liegewiesen wo sich die
leute bequem machen können sich sonnen
können und gesehen und gesehen werden in
unmittelbarer nähe zum pool befindet
sich der hauseigene sm bereich direkt
unter freiem himmel
ein bauzaun sorgt dabei für die nötigen
sichtschutz dann haben wir hier unseren
bock wo die damen sich darüber legen
können
hier haben wir noch ein andreaskreuz da
wird der mensch also die dame oder der
her fixiert und dann kann der partner
mit peitsche oder was auch immer an ihr
spielen das ist echt eine schwere zeit
traurige zeit für uns heute einfach mal
so viel gemacht haben so viel herzblut
reingesteckt haben und kann es nicht
wirklich nützen aber es kommt und dann
feiern das richtig
ja ich würde mal sagen das beste draus
gemacht aber natürlich wirft das auch
wieder probleme auf zb mit der
nachbarschaft an kempkens nehmen wir mal
an dieser biergarten befindet sich in
meiner umgebung und da ist dann wirklich
sehr sehr lautes treiben das bringt mich
doch als nachbarn wirklich total auf die
palme ist denn das so ok einfach aus dem
biergarten swingerclub zu machen
also das ist natürlich sehr umstritten
in den einzelnen wohngebieten und der
klubs sind nicht überall immer gerne
gesehen da sind die meinungen sehr
unterschiedlich muss man ehrlicherweise
sagen und da kommt es so auf die
örtlichen verhältnisse an
es gibt die bauleitplanung und die
bauleitplanung die lässt es eben zu dass
in bestimmten baugebieten eben eine
bestimmte nutzung zulässig ist und eine
andere nutzung nicht zulässig ist
und wenn wir hier so die genehmigung
erst als finger club im innenbereich
haben und dann hätte genehmigung im
außenbereich erteilt wird das ist
natürlich ein besonderes baurechtliche
verfahren das ist völlig klar
dann wird das ebenso gemacht und ich bin
mal sehr auf den winter gespannt muss
ich ehrlicherweise sagen und da dürfte
es hier besonders prickelnd werden
absolut das kann man sich in etwa
vorstellen aber tatsächlich nehmen wir
mal an die gute nachricht ist natürlich
dieses ehepaar hat wirklich aus der not
eine tugend gemacht
das ist ja das was sie auch sich von
anderen menschen vielleicht auch
wünschen die nicht so engstirnig
weitermachen sondern wirklich ihren
blick öffnen
das heißt also ich verlege zum beispiel
sachen ins internet oder auch vielleicht
nach draußen wie gegner am besten vor
nehmen wir mal an ich bin da jetzt kein
unternehmensexperte also ist natürlich
ganz wichtiger punkt also hier die
dienstleistung die ich erbringe bzw das
angebot vor sich habe wenn ich das jetzt
nach draußen bringen ist natürlich eine
tolle idee und das ist auch das was wir
im grunde genommen auch gerade in dieser
sendung ja schon seit wochen monaten
besprechen immer so dass dieser blick
nach vorne gar nicht so zurück den
status halten sondern einfach neue ideen
entwickeln und daher vorher finde ich
diese idee her super toll und finde dass
also ich bin das findet meine volle
unterstützung
und das geht natürlich also das geht
auch allen branchen so wenn man
beispielsweise nach draußen gehen kann
sollte man erst mal am besten mit einem
architekten besprechen ob das
baurechtlich zulässig ist dann kann man
sofort an fragen machen beim bauamt
fragen ja wir haben das und das vor hier
im außenbereich ist dass in diesem es
gibt beispielsweise ein reines
wohngebiet oder es gibt so gemischte
gebiete es gibt industriegebiete das
sind sie ja drei so einstufungen und
dann kann ich sehen in welchem gebiet
bin ich und dann fragt man beim bauern
ist dieses vorhaben was ich habe ist
dass in diesem baugebiet zulässig ja
oder nein
und dann kann man so ein vorbescheid
kriegen und dann lohnt es sich geld zu
investieren zu planen und zu bauen und
dann kann man natürlich vorher den
bauantrag stellen da kriegt man das
genehmigt geht relativ schnell im moment
machen wir eigentlich ganz gute
erfahrung und dann kann es eben
weitergehen